so thanks to be here for this talk about
backend for front end
I have a one hour slot I won't fill it
so if at any point you want to ask
questions or make comments or whatever
feel free I prefer the talk to be
interactive
especially since during the pandemics I
talk to my screen a lot and the screen
doesn't tend to ask questions and it's a
bit boring so yeah back to on on sites
events we talk to people
if you don't have questions that's fine
too
I'm Nicola Frankel
I've been a developer for two decades
which is probably a long time for most
of you and I worked mainly on the gvm I
worked on the Java platform spring well
before spring Java ee then spring
a couple of years ago where I started to
do some kotlin I love kotlin who knows
about kotlin
wow it's not a net developer conference
that could I thought that NDC was.net
but I'm learning rest at the moment like
by leaps and downs it's really really
interesting
um
and a couple of years ago I also decided
that I had enough of projects because
there were like those uh like customers
and they already add like strange
requirements and in general
organizations they want you to solve
their organizational problems with
Technical Solutions
and when you your scope is the technical
scope then it's not that fun so I became
a developer advocate so now if you don't
care about my advices that's fine
I won't know it so everything will be
fine
as I mentioned I've been working for
some time already and when I started
working this was what we did
that was amazing right
server generated pages
but now it's back full circle again as I
understand but yeah that that's what we
did it worked very well
um
I can show you some crazy code like
Hello World type of code because now I'm
a developer advocate so I'm not supposed
to do something complex besides I
perhaps I'm not a developer anymore I I
developed the stuff in Python so I hope
that's fine with you who here is a
python developer
well there are nobody
no pyth one person okay
yeah I I mean I'm lower than that so
that's fine okay
and I thought wow perhaps I will talk to
people I will I will do some python even
though I don't know python it will make
like you know the relation better but
nobody here knows python air should have
done it in kotlin but anyway so here
it's it's a flask application I don't
use a database because I'm super lazy so
I have data that is in arrays then I
have like three routes
first route is for products
route is for news third round is for
debugging information very important
most developers they don't care about it
but I do and then the main routes
Aggregates everything and returns
everything in one go so here it's not
like a page that is generated server
side but it's like fits this model that
in general you have like one single and
one single endpoint and then you have
something that queries it and you get
all the data and everybody is happy
but of course
it didn't stay like that for long
because afterwards there were phones and
tablets and devices and whatever
and so we add the same
thing we still add like a server
endpoints but we had to deliver data for
all those different devices
and of course we could still do the same
we deliver everything
and then on each device
you need
to remove what you don't want
okay
and that's not a great idea because
first every device needs to do it which
is additional like
computing power that you lose on each
device which is not super nice for the
user and then
on the network side if you return whole
payloads and you might use only
a part of it which from an engineering
site is not that great as well so of
course now everybody has 5G right
yeah that's the point when I usually
goes from Everybody Has 5G no no
sometimes you don't even have 4G like
depending when where you are so be nice
to your user be considerate just return
what you need
but
it gets
better because you say okay we can
actually be smart and just return what
the device needs
so you might have a different route you
might have a query parameter you might
have a header
then when you request the end points it
returns you the data that you need and
only the data that you need
so they are kotlin's developers perhaps
they are Java developers
no Java developer
interesting so
kotlin developers you are Android
developers right
no there are no more kotlin developers
they just disappeared in like five
minutes where are my content Developers
for what
sorry okay so no python
no Java no kotlin
net Developers
that's what I thought okay and then all
my references get lost because well I
don't know.nets
um
it's it will be hard but I try to
communicate it
um what we did in the time we tried to
return like generic data and then on the
server side we added what we call the
Chevrolet filters or if you want just
filters and basically depending on the
device that was asking the data we just
like filter it here
that was
fun and nice and everybody was happy
and now came
the fun stuff
the micro Services Revolution
who here does Micro services
you don't
yeah you do you do okay I will return
the question who here doesn't do micro
services
couple of hands yeah
people who do micro services are very
proud because that's hype and well
that's a good way to get higher
I'm not kidding actually I'm very
serious
um
but I think a bit differently
and so just because I'm French and we
like to complain give me a couple of
minutes to rent
we are
in an industry that right now says that
micro services are good I mean I don't
know if you like went to a couple of
talk that was the Grail now you wanted
to do microservices and monoliths are
bad
no
I also but that's the state of the
industry nonetheless
and well I again give me a couple of
slides to try perhaps to instill some
kind of critical thought into that
this is the definition of microservices
by Martin Fuller
I don't event anything if you are
unhappy with it just bring it tomorrow
I'm not responsible
whether you like it or not that's what I
will use in the same blog post that I
reference it here you can find like
characteristics of microservices
and in general
all the technical aspects
are respected
but the last bullet point is not one
technical aspect it's how you handle
how you manage
so now let me
rephrase re-ask the question oh here
does Micro Services according to those
characteristics especially the last one
meaning you are doing products and not
projects meaning that you have recurring
budget from year to year of course can
change whereas a project as a start date
and an end date
now who does microservices according to
this definition
so we went to like nearly everybody
to two and two halves
that's very interesting
so basically according to Modern Fuller
you don't do micro services so you can
remove it from your resume right now
I will check afterwards
let's get a bit further
I'm sure that everybody has heard about
Conway's law
it's okay if you tell me no again this
is a discussion
everybody has heard of Conway's law
okay great
so the ID and and this is Melvin Conway
by the way so I was very happy to take a
selfie
Pride
um the idea is that
if you have an organizational structure
then your architecture will reflect
the communication in the structure
and when I started
hearing about microservices five six
seven years ago
it was very clear
every talk about microservices said you
must reverse Conway's law
meaning that right now we have layer
based architecture and the reason is
that we have like layer organized teams
so if you want to have a micro Services
architecture
you must have independent
teams
again who here
as this kind of organization don't be
shy
most of you do
no nobody dares and okay and who have
this kind of organization
oh really wow that's cool
I in general it's about the same number
of people who do products that's really
cool so okay there let's say
30 percent of the room
are organized like this and nobody
organized like this so that if 70 I
don't know how you are organized
so either you are too shy to admit it
which is fine or something else so can
somebody who hasn't raised their hand
tell me how they are organized between
this and this or something else
I feel like like a school teacher asking
the students and nobody like you all
look at your shoes I'm I'm not that
impressive I told you I'm French that's
fine
okay forget it so still this is a high
number of people who do like this
so if you're organized like this
microservices might be a thing
the problem is
30 is already for me a high number so
it's like you know product not projects
if we go into the detail there might be
some grain of true so it might be a bit
different the problem if you have like a
legacy organization organized around
like this and you want to migrate around
like this
who will be in your way to do this
what does the guy looks like
there is a hint he has a suit and a tie
do I look like I have a suit and a tie
can show you I'm French
um
no this guy is a middle manager
so the person who can help you going
from this kind of organization to this
kind of organization other middle
managers
right so in this organization
the middle managers are at the top here
there is one middle manager for the UI
team one here and one here
where are the middle managers in this
schema
they are gone
so basically the person the people who
can help you migrate your organization
from
your legacy States
the 2B state
are the people who will be made
irrelevant
they won't have a job anymore
it's really really hard right
it's not going to happen nobody
well not many people are going
to make themselves jobless just for hey
the sake of the greater Goods
so that's the reason why I think that
most organization most Legacy
organizations
are not suited to microservices because
they don't have the right kind of
organization
only when you start from scratch
no middle managers
and just for fun
if is there any middle manager in the
room or I can be offensive a bit
one okay you will come afterwards I will
give you some chocolates then
I will make up for it
um
I so first I've met a couple of good
middle managers in my life
sorry
okay I I I've really worked for a couple
of them if you find one please follow
them everywhere they are very rare most
of the middle managers I've met in my
career
actually
they were paid to approve my vacation
requests
which in general well was just like
stamping because every body on the team
was happy or if they weren't happy they
would have told no
then to be the proxy for your race at
each early interview
I mean proxy because you cannot
negotiate right is we give you this yeah
but it was decided
thank you
and the third is reporting
so basically your manager is
a not so good bot that takes data and
put it in an Excel file
or Google sheet if they are modern
or Office 365 if you are on the
macrosoft stack
and they get a lot of money for that
that's not funny
so if you find a good one is really
helpful whose job is to remove the
blocks in your job well for them
so I've rented a bit and my point is
microservices are
an organizational mess
because you need to migrate your
organization or you keep it the same way
then you will get none of the benefits
of microservices and all the issues
now from a technical point of view
because I assume that nobody will listen
to my advice anyway that's what I told
you at the beginning
you will address it from the technical
point of view and from the technical
point of view it completely breaks what
we did before
because now
your phone needs to receive data from
service 1 service 2 and service 3. which
means that not only do they need to
actually make X calls depending on how
many services do you need
but on the back end side that means that
the team in charge of a service needs to
care about the phone and the browser and
the tablet and whatever
and this concern needs to be replicated
along each service
and of course there is like an explosion
of cardinality if you add one more on
each side
so my solution which is not my solution
is to have something on the back end
that is handled managed developed and
deployed by the front-end team
it means that
this new components will actually
Aggregate and filter the data that is
just necessary for the phone because
who better knows what they need than the
phone team
and they are close to the service so you
make a single request here you make
multiple but you are close so that's not
that hard
and everything works as expected
this is an organizational decision
and the problem is this is an
organizational decision this is an
organizational pattern and people
tech people I think I'm a tech person
we translate it into a technical pattern
like straightforwardly
it means
that we generally do something like this
so I've shown you
my ID of the monolith which again is
really really bad everybody knows it
and I transform everything into a
microservice
and I added
a backend Forefront and I will directly
do like this because like this is not
really interesting
so here now I have
separated my micro Services is only two
basically is really stupid I've just
created an endpoint for the product and
an endpoint for the info
and here I have the news and I've
created guess what
an end point for the news and an
endpoint for the debug or info
so also I I need to have an else check
for every service nowadays
and I agree get them
as the following
I still have my rounds
and here I will do the request on the
back end
and aggregate them however I want here I
decided that I will have
an attribute for the product and
attribute for your news and a single
attribute for all the debug information
from all the different endpoints so if I
show you my Docker compose file
here and this is how it works API 6 I
will just talk about it a bit later and
I have my catalog my news
and
not my best friend forever my back and
forth front-end
um
let's see how it works docker
compose down I will just remove
everything just to be sure
and up
it was really really fast it's a bit
strange but normally it should work as
expected so I can curl local hosts
90 and I say just at the roots and yeah
it it works
so I have everything if I
GQ it I can have it in a nicely
formatted way
so that's what I told you I have the
info endpoint and I get
like nested
the health or info whatever information
for each service then I have the data
that I want
it means that well
here I've written everything in Python
but as I mentioned that's not so a great
idea because yeah the backend team
writes in Python but the front-end team
writes in whatever
probably I don't know about any
front-end technology in Python
JavaScript yeah or if you are an Android
developer you would write kotlin code
again or Java code or dotnet for mobile
which I don't know if it exists but I
have no clue but well you can fix it for
yourself
so the idea is that as I mentioned is an
architectural pattern that many many
implementation and since
here I'm using an API Gateway
who knows what's an API Gateway by the
way
who doesn't know what's an API getaway
okay
I'm always a bit worried that's fine but
again if you don't ask me questions I
will assume that it works I'm using an
API Gateway so the idea is that you can
do the exact same stuff
but you translate it
in the IPA getaway
so instead of having a python
here I have just a plugin inside the API
Gateway it's still the same team that
deploys it
but it's another implementation
and perhaps there are more at ease with
it
so
it's all about independent development
and deployment
has nothing to do with anything else
it's not a technical requirement
um
I work on the Apache ipa6 project who
has heard about Apache api6
nobody or perhaps to shine I don't know
in some countries it's because of
shyness
but the more I talk the less people
raise their hand they always feel that
like there is a trap afterwards
so it's
an API Gateway built on nginx who knows
about nginx
okay that was not a trap that was cool
so it's really robust reverse proxy on
top of it the problem of nginx is if you
want to change any of the configuration
you need to stop the service
which is not that great in this day and
age like you don't want to have a static
web page saying hey we are back in a few
minutes huh
Facebook doesn't do it your grandmother
probably wouldn't understand what it
means we know well all people know what
it means but us the family don't so we
have open resty open resty is a Lua
engine on top of nginx that allows you
to script your nginx configuration
and then we've got plugins and the
plugins allow you to get like out of the
box already prepared common use cases
but you can still write your own stuff
which is exactly what I did here
so what I did here is I changed my
architecture again
and now my architecture on the docker
compose file
is back to what it was before so there
is no dedicated python app for front end
everything is in API 6. so there are two
ways to deploy API 6 the first is with
etcd if you have Dynamic configuration
the tcd is a key distributed key Value
Store the same one used by kubernetes
it's pretty robust but here what I'm
using I'm using static files so you can
use it in a like GitHub sway
up to you
and what I did I created
the same codes that I did before is
there any Lua developer here
good I'm I'm not a Lua developer either
so I can show it to you you can
criticize my code so basically sorry
I've created a generic
function to fetch the data from an
endpoint here I've created all the
endpoints that I wanted and then I go
through all the structure and I get
everything and I aggregate everything
and I put it in Json formats
the only thing that they need to do is
configure API 6 to have like a virtual
endpoint because normally
an API getaway should actually like
forward somewhere here I create this
virtual endpoint to say okay I will
handle it by myself which is not the
usual use case General you forward
so I can start it again
and from the customer side the user side
it shouldn't change anything
I think I know why it starts so fast I
didn't rebuild
hmm
okay
so I didn't cheat you on purpose but I
still cheated
curl okay and if I curl again
JQ yes
so you still have the same
results
even though the architecture has changed
and the organization is still the same
you still have your backend for front
end but in this case instead of having a
dedicated component it's just a plug-in
inside
of the API getaway
every team can have their own plugin
that they deploy independently
so it doesn't mean that like this
pattern needs to be implemented in a
certain way you have multiple ways to do
that
if you have an API getaway and you don't
want to code any lure depending on on
the API Gateway but it's possible in the
pressure bi6 you can do a bulk fetch so
basically you still will do one request
from the front end
to the API Gateway no code no nothing
and on the API Gateway you configure
something generic that does all the
calls and you get return all the data so
we are back to square one only we have
one single call
so it's quick and dirty you get some
benefits not all of them but it still
works
good
as I mentioned
it won't be one hour
please don't do microservices
really don't really really don't
as I mentioned you won't listen to me or
perhaps you are already like neck deep
in microservices you cannot live I can
understand it yeah
um
but if you do and if you have multiple
device types then backend from front end
is one pattern that you can use
think about it I will repeat it it's an
organizational pattern there is no
direct straightforward implementation
you can create your own components using
the language you want you can use an API
Gateway and perhaps there is something
that I didn't think about
very important
to go beyond the scope of this talk
every problem
is an organization problem
people problem are still simple
if we or both of those of you have this
agreement
I can talk we can have a meeting you are
smart people we will come to a consensus
worst case I will fire one of you
or both
this is easy to fix
what is very very hard
impossible to fix
or organizational issues
there are so many organizational
problems that we need to cope with that
make no sense
stupid stuff
you said you were a middle manager so
basically you need to report to somebody
in general
you're in metrics
there are two kinds of metrics
vanity metrics that are easy to compute
that tell you nothing
or metrics that are very very hard to
compute
and well it takes time or it takes money
or whatever
other stupid organizational statements
you have a company
you divide it into silos
you try to optimize one single silo
and you think that the sum of all local
optimums gives you the global Optimum
who here believes it
that's completely crazy
guess what
every one of us is still doing that
you've got a company you've got only two
departments
you give budgets to Department a you
give budget to Department B
Department a at the end of the year
needs budget they already like
spent everything
Department B
didn't
what happens
how long does it take forever
so basically you have a department that
needs money it will never get it
only because at the beginning
you decided
to split the money into virtual buckets
see that I'm I'm only complaining I'm
not providing you any solution the
French way right
um
but it's still an issue but if only I
could make you think about what we take
for granted most of the rules
that either we apply to ourselves or
that the organization puts on us
most of the rules operate is stupid
they don't help us at all
that actually makes
out they make our work harder
sometimes even impossible
if you find yourself in such an
organization you have two solutions
be demotivated until you retire
and in general I must admit they give
you a lot of money for your demotivation
Olive
thanks a lot I'm Nicola Frankel you can
follow me on Twitter you can I I want to
make a social experiment if you have a
mastered account please follow me there
and I want to count how many people are
on Muslim because you know there is this
great shift from Twitter to Mastodon and
it doesn't seem to translate so far with
my experience
if you are interested about the the code
though it's in Python I mean I could
write it you can probably read it
um you can check it I've made all the
commits the git commit steps as one of
the steps I've described so you can
follow around see the differences and if
I got you interested in apachea bi6 of
course you are welcome to have a look
it's an Apache product it's managed by
the Apache foundation so basically it
will be free and maintain well free
forever maintain depending on who is
interested
and that's good I don't know how much
time do we have but we have well we have
time for questions
so I will be very happy to have
discussions now
or not
sorry
who is the middle manager you mean among
you
yeah
who is the middle manager I I no I don't
snitch
I don't snitch I'm not well actually
like officially I am but uh
[Music]
I have very independent people like me
so that's fine
um
other questions or comments or whatever
yes
could be like the stuff you're selling
with like microservices that could be
done uh instead with unlike different
teams working on sort of front in the
back end like that could probably be
done with like product URL where you can
like also filter stuff out as the
volunteer can you take the mic please
you should be the one to know
um with a like a the stuff with like
filtering and stuff like that when you
have different teams working on uh sort
of different parts of the application
when you think like something like a
graphql would be quite helpful with that
and like just sort of uh using like a
Federated server or something like that
to actually like consume all your
services that you have uh and then being
able to communicate that with your uh
Dev team on the front end
yeah graphql is definitely an option
also I was a back consultant because I
was able to say I don't have enough
experience
so here in that case I don't have enough
experience to tell you whether graphql
is
a good solution a good technical
solution to this problem
I think not
but I cannot tell you hey this is the
reason so I need to delve deeper into it
as far as understand
graphql has issues on its own
and again in my opinion if you have an
organizational issue and you try to
solve it with technical solution
it's going to have many Ripple effects
so probably it's possible but there
might be side effects that you don't
want
but it's an option of course
other questions
I have a question for you
I don't know about I mean some of you
are young some of you are not that young
do you feel like me that you have to
cope more with organizational problems
than we've
technical problems and both yes or no
are fine I just want to understand
[Laughter]
if if you wanted to know one with a
manager is it's a Dev manager or head of
engineering could be a better manager
though I came from a developer
background
which is fine because now you know
all the problems that your team has to
solve and you can try to Shield them
from yeah
unblock them so you see this is one if
if he's right if he speaks the truth
which I cannot assume is one of the few
middle managers you can work for uh yeah
indeed
and we maybe just
hook up a product area that's
Integrations with third parties and we
move people from the other teams and one
of their delivery managers say well the
other teams have got quite small they're
just birds and I said don't need dirt
because they're on the product the
product Specialists on those teams so
leave them alone because they need to
work on that and if you merge them they
will never come back we need them in the
future in about six months when we add
more developers into them where you
heard
is in a backlog work for them to do yeah
where you heard
that's good
because most of
most of the frustration I had as a tech
person was nobody listened to me
of course perhaps it's the way I talk
but even when I took very nicely and it
was like a lot of effort for not that
much result so anybody else has like the
same experience as as I have regarding
the organizational problems and the
technical problems or
in general my experience is that the
older you get
the more you get the same feeling
because you get like exposed to more
to wider problems
of course when you are on your code when
you are you start working on on like
your young engineer young developer you
start working well you won't be exposed
to this kind of problem your problem
will be hey should I use a hashmap or a
list or linked list or like a doubly
linked list or whatever
that's fine I mean
that was happy times
and if you get into like techlade and
Architects and solution architect then
I I was exposed to this kind of stuff so
thanks a lot for your attention
um I will be there until tomorrow noon
if you have questions and you were too
shy to ask them in front then just
please come and thanks again enjoy the
rest of the conference
foreign